and we were thinking about this today
but you know because you've done so much
filming over the years you've been on
location you've been in all sorts of
extraordinary situations we've we've
seen them we remember them what was what
were the times when you felt most in
danger where you really thought this
might be it no not very often actually I
suppose the time when I really thought
maybe this was not doing going too well
was well I was in with a very great
expert an East African expert knew about
big game he was a great elephant expert
and I was traveling with him in a Land
Rover through through some Africa and we
were driving on peppy happy and I heard
a sort of disappeared and my expert
friend said did you hear that and I said
what he said well not that noise then I
said yes he said that was a we were
charged by Rhino really oh yes it's a
dummy charge that's what they do
dummy charges they they come out and
they just child and then if they drive
off it no no bother at all so I was a
long man sting and then suddenly those
this noise again and this time it ended
with a boom I said the Land Rover it was
picked up by these horns on the from the
back end sure about that yeah and of
course
and and I saw this chaps I remember his
hands on the steering wheels white
knuckles see and we went out then he
went boom again this time we went on the
back wheel and for an event the day the
Rhino went backwards and retreated I
said that was a hell of a dummy
well and that woman and this time he
almost destroyed the Land Rover in all
we did was to sit there and if you've
gone out that would have been dangerous
but as it was I just hope that the
people who built the Land Rover and done
all the nuts up tight no that was the
worst such words I've had yeah well I
know someone else on the couch has had a
memorable encounter with nature now Matt
Smith you were I believe we you were the
ladies right now we're in a garden or
were you in a field where were you oh
the wasps yes well I was under a sort of
veranda it was like a Moroccan rat this
is a while ago on my ad but I was under
a sort of veranda and we were you know
we were we were we were we were we were
yes she was on top and I you know did
you get an idea sorry sorry to be crass
but anyway to cut very long and terrible
stories Thank You Craig okay what
happened was she sort of mid thrust as
it were this is true it is terribly true
I was stung I was stung on me good so I
sort of yelled out and she obviously
thought it was incredible hopping around
and the bloody wasp would start me on
the knockers
oh thanks for the role the doorman
graham norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation